auf der suche nach einem ausweg wann
kommt das ende der korona sperrmaßnahmen
und wie soll die exit strategie aussehen
in ersten kliniken in deutschland werden
die intensivbetten knapp patienten
können aber von anderen krankenhäusern
aufgenommen werden
boris johnson corona positiv getestet
der britische premierminister zeigt
milde symptome und ist in häuslicher
isolation
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten an diesem freitag am
ende eine arbeitswoche wie sie so noch
nie in deutschland gegeben hat
die innenstädte verweist fitnessstudios
schwimmbäder und restaurants geschlossen
nur wenige geschäfte sind offen dennoch
scheint die mehrheit der bevölkerung
dies zu akzeptieren auch dass seine
erfahrung für deutschland die wirtschaft
mahnt aber auch an die folgen zu denken
sollte dieser zustand länger anhalten
und fordert eine klare exit-strategie
von der politik david sauer
was folgt auf den ausnahmezustand
und wann ist das risiko beherrschbar das
land wieder in den vor corinna alltag
zurück zu versetzen
seit tagen gibt es forderungen den
einstieg in den ausstieg zu planen
auch angesichts der immensen kosten klar
ist natürlich dass wir uns so ein
zustand wie heute zwei drei vielleicht
vier wochen leisten können vielleicht
auch eine woche mehr aber nicht drei
vier monate dann gerät der staat an
seine grenzen ein exit sei erst möglich
wenn sich eine trendwende abzeichnet
sagt die bundeskanzlerin als so
ambitionierte pläne hält sie für
voreilig das zeigen die daten der
amerikanischen johns hopkins universität
demnach gibt es bislang 49 1344
bestätigte infektionen 304 menschen sind
gestorben
eine verlangsamung ist noch nicht zu
erkennen im gegenteil
der bislang größte tages zuwachs seit
ausbruch der seuche wurde gestern
nachgewiesen
etwa 6600 tendenz steigend als blaupause
für ganz deutschland könnte der kreis
heinsberg dienen
dort gab es früher viele fälle und eine
ausgangs beschränkung der kreis ist im
rest deutschlands etwa drei wochen
voraus und meldet fortschritte
eine studie dort soll jetzt helfen
nachzuzeichnen wie genau sich das virus
dort ausbreiten
der landkreis heinsberg ist eine chance
ist es eine chance für rest von
deutschland informationen zu sammeln und
praktische hinweise zu geben wie man in
der zukunft mit der saas profi zwei
umgehen kann mit einer verfünffachung
der tests bis ende april wollen forscher
und politik dem virus nun bei kommen
dazu müssen die laborkapazitäten
deutlich erhöht werden etwa auch in dem
tier medizinische einrichtungen
mithelfen
in erwartung weiter steigender
infektionszahlen arbeiten die
krankenhäuser im land massiv daran ihre
kapazitäten auf den intensivstationen
auszubauen
das ziel der bundesregierung die zahl
der intensiv plätze zu verdoppeln bisher
gab es in deutschland 20.000 plätze an
denen menschen beatmet werden konnten in
den letzten wochen wurden die wurde die
zahl auf 30.000 erhöht
noch sei die situation beherrschbar
sagen experten in kritischen gebeten
sind die kliniken aber teilweise schon
voll
schwenkers berichtet auf schnellstem weg
mussten sie in andere krankenhäuser
gebracht werden
vier corona patienten aus nürtingen den
baden-württemberg-wahl am nürtinger
klinikum zu viele infizierte versorgt
werden mussten es keine beatmungs
kapazitäten mehr gab lagen gestern
spitzte sich dramatisch zu wie waren
nicht mehr in der lage weitere patienten
beatmen zu können da unsere komplette
intensivstation die wir extra fico mit
19 erkrankten eingerichtet haben bereits
mit integrierten patienten voll belegt
war
inzwischen hat sich die lage in
nürtingen zumindest wieder so weit
entspannt dass alle die beatmet werden
müssen auch beatmet werden können
doch die zahl der korona patienten nimmt
weiter stark zu auch anderswo
bundesweit sind inzwischen rund 1000
corona patienten auf intensivstationen
gemeldet damit gibt es in deutschland
insgesamt zwar aktuell genug betten
vereinzelt aber dennoch engpässe die
auch die auflistung im sogenannten
intensiv register zeigt in einzelnen
kliniken steht die ampel bereits jetzt
auf rot die intensivstationen dort voll
wir haben ja nach wie vor auch noch
andere patienten die schwer krank sind
herzinfarktpatienten usw
das kann in einzelnen krankenhäusern zu
solchen überbelegungen und
kapazitätsengpässen führen aber nicht
global und auch nicht in regionen
dadurch dass bundesweit intensiv
kapazitäten ausgebaut wurden sieht die
krankenhausgesellschaft die kliniken gut
vorbereitet zumindest auf die erwarteten
fallzahlen der nächsten zwei wochen in
nürtingen stellen sie sich dennoch schon
auf belastende zeiten ein wir werden
auch in diese situation kommen
bubi an die grenzen der belastbarkeit
kommen die situation ist sehr ernst und
das noch mal mein appell an alle bleiben
wieder heim
denn nur wenn die fallzahl nicht zu
schnell ansteigen haben die kliniken im
land eine chance auch noch in einigen
wochen alle bestmöglich zu behandeln in
einem freiheitlichen land wie der
bundesrepublik funktionieren anhaltende
einschränkungen der persönlichen
freiheit nur wenn die bevölkerung
mitzieht
selten war ein politbarometer deshalb so
spannend wie dieses heute das uns
matthias fornoff mitgebracht hat
matthias guten aber da sammeln was
denken eigentlich die menschen bei uns
über die politik zur eindämmung der
korona krise war petra die deutschen
sehen auf jeden fall ein dass dringend
gehandelt werden muss und sind ganz
überwiegend einverstanden mit den
beschlossenen maßnahmen
insgesamt wird genug getan zum schutz
vor dem corona virus das sagen mehr als
drei viertel der befragten noch einmal
ein zuwachs gegenüber dem wert vor drei
wochen
es ist wohl niemand glücklich über
ausgangs und kontakt beschränkungen die
nächste grafik zeigt dennoch eine
überwältigende zustimmung
die einschränkungen sind angemessen das
finden 95 prozent der deutschen nur fünf
prozent bezweifeln das
und wie wirkt sich das prozedere für die
parteien politisch aus cdu und csu sind
deutlich gestärkt die afg verliert an
zustimmung
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union auf 33 prozent plus 7 ihr
bester wert seit fast zwei jahren spd 15
prozent -1 afd 10 prozent minus 4 fdp 6
linke 8 beide unverändert
die grünen 22 prozent minus 1 schwarz
grün hätte demnach eine mehrheit auch
für union und spd würde es erstmals seit
eineinhalb jahren wieder knapp reichen
zum schluss noch die frage wie schätzen
die menschen eigentlich ihre private
ihre persönliche situation ein wie
sicher oder wie unsicher fühlen sie sich
klar bei immer weiter steigenden
infektionszahlen gibt es natürlich eine
unsicherheit der ernst der lage wird
zunehmend erkannt dass sie ihn wäre hier
mehr als jeder zweite sieht seine eigene
gesundheit gefährdet vor drei wochen war
es nur jeder fünfte
tatsächlich selbst schwer zu erkranken
das befürchten aber die wenigsten und
drei viertel gehen davon aus dass die
menschen in deutschland sich vernünftig
verhalten
das wäre dann ja mal sowas wie ein
hoffnungsschimmer interessante befunde
vielen dank der firma und noch mehr
details zum neuen politbarometer sehen
sie wie immer im heute journal um die
folgen der krise abzumildern hat der
bundesrat im eiltempo das mammut
hilfspaket verabschiedet das volumen
mehr als 120 milliarden euro
für kleine unternehmen und selbständige
gibt es direkte zuschüsse das ziel
arbeitsplätze sichern
eltern die wegen geschlossener kitas
ihre kinder zu hause betreuen müssen
erhalten befristet finanzielle
unterstützung und für mieter die wegen
der krise ihre miete nicht bezahlen
können wurde ein kündigungsschutz schutz
beschlossen
schauen wir nach frankreich platz
schaffen für noch schwerere fälle die
verlegung vieler corona patienten stellt
die krankenhäuser dort vor schwere
probleme
denn die welle der infizierungen reißt
nicht ab
besonders betroffen der großraum paris
und das elsass von hier werden kranke
auch nach deutschland gebracht thomas
walther berichtet dr jannik gott weil
ist chef der notaufnahme im louis
pasteur krankenhaus von colmar
frankreichs corona hotspot ist das
elsass und der hot spot des elsass ist
hier die patientin die sie hinter mir
sehen ist gerade reingekommen sie hat
atemprobleme eine lungeninfektion und in
der gegenwärtigen pandemie haben wir den
starken verdacht dass siegfried hat seit
tagen arbeitet die station nicht nur an
sondern jenseits der belastungsgrenze
sechs unserer patienten sind heute mit
dem tgv abtransportiert worden alle
plätze wurden sofort neu belegt wir
haben zwei transporte nach deutschland
auch damit haben wir probleme die
nötigen platz für andere zu finden
die madridista problem fast 30 patienten
wurden mit einem umgebauten schnellzug
aus dem elsass in andere teile des
landes gebracht und das militär hat ein
feldlazarett errichtet für weitere 30
patienten
doch weil die zum teil wochenlang
beatmet werden müssen reicht es hinten
und vorne nicht
das problem ist die mangelnde
ausstattung alle beklagen sich darüber
fehlende beatmungsgeräte und material
zum schutz des personals
es ist dramatisch wenn das personal sich
nicht selbst schützen kann wird es ernst
für das wochenende erwartet die
regierung die bisher größte welle neuer
fälle
sie bedrohe so die regierung das gesamte
gesundheitssystem des landes
italien bleibt einer der krisenherde der
korona pandemie das land zählte in den
letzten 24 stunden 969 tote die nation
mit den meisten registrierten corona
infektionen weltweit ist seit gestern
abend die usa die vereinigten staaten
haben jetzt mehr als 92.000 fälle eine
entwicklung die viele experten
befürchtet hatten
brennpunkte sind große städte wie new
york und new orleans
dort könnten die karnevalsfeiern vor
einigen wochen zu vielen ansteckungen
geführt haben nach großbritannien dort
ist die zahl der korona fälle in den
vergangenen tagen stark gestiegen
578 menschen sind gestorben rund 11.700
sind positiv getestet seit heute
nachmittag zählt auch premierminister
boris johnson dazu er habe etwas
temperatur und beständigen husten die
amtsgeschäfte laufen aber weiter per
video-konferenz kurz darauf meldet auch
gesundheitsminister hancock er sei
ebenfalls infiziert aus london yasin
heran
er ist ein abend sah man boris johnson
noch mal draußen vor der tür von number
10 downing street weise mit den
finanzministern aber teil am
landesweiten beifall klatschen für die
angestellten des gesundheitswesens nun
kann der premierminister aus erster hand
berichten wie das ist mit dem virus
erkrankt zu sein und über wird morgen
die zeige milde symptome das heißt eine
erhöhte temperatur und einen anhaltenden
husten
daraufhin wurde mir geraten einen test
zu machen der war positiv ich arbeite
jetzt von zu hause bei den
regierungsgeschäften wurde zuletzt
verschärft abstand gehalten wie hier bei
der fragestunde im parlament
pressekonferenzen fanden nur noch per
videolink stadt doch das kam
möglicherweise zu spät auch der
gesundheitsminister ist inzwischen
positiv getestet worden und
außenminister dominik rapp der
gegebenenfalls für johnson
einspringen müsste wurde erst vorgestern
noch in der downing street gesehen gut
für die beiden verantwortlichen
politiker dass sie nur leichte symptome
zeigen wer jetzt in großbritannien am
corona virus schwer erkrankt sieht sich
mit erheblichen engpässen im über lange
jahre unterfinanzierten gesundheitswesen
konfrontiert schon zu normalen zeiten
ist es oft überlastet jetzt fehlen vor
allem intensivstation betten im osten
londons wurde daher unterdessen begonnen
ein not krankenhaus für bis zu 4000
patienten einzurichten
die kurve der krankheits und todesfälle
schnellt in die höhe
gestern waren erstmals über 100 neue
todesfälle hinzugekommen heute waren es
weitere 181 vor allem in der hauptstadt
rolle ein tsunami auf die krankenhäuser
zu warnen ärzte die kritik dass strenge
maßnahmen die ausgangs beschränkungen zu
spät erfolgten wird immer lauter
ein historischer moment vor wenigen
minuten auf dem petersplatz im vatikan
der papst hat sich an die gläubigen
weltweit gewarnt mit einem ganz
besonderen segen der katholischen kirche
orbi der stadt und dem erdkreis heute in
stiller form sonst spendet das oberhaupt
der katholischen kirche diesen segen nur
an weihnachten zu ostern und kurz nach
einer papstwahl und zehntausende aus
aller welt jubeln sie und alle anderen
hatte papst franziskus diesmal
eingeladen zu hause mit zu beten für ein
schnelles ende der pandemie die kritik
am land tirol und vor allem dem
wintersportort ischgl als mögliche
keimzellen des corona virus in europa
reißt nicht ab
der vorwurf die behörden sollen schon
früh von infektionen gewusst wenn
skibetrieb aber erst spät geschlossen
haben
britta hilpert und wolf christian ulrich
berichten
so sieht das skiparadies ischgl heute
aus alles zu quarantäne seit dreizehnter
märz der wird der abriss über kids loch
hat uns diese bilder geschickt bei ihm
wurde der erste mitarbeiter positiv
getestet sagt er im exklusiv gespräch
mit dem zdf
das ist ihm dass er so oft dass wir uns
gegenseitig anstecken und das eine
grippewelle ich und dadurch ich das
eigentlich nicht so schnell erkennbar
gewesen dass es sich wirklich um den
videos handelt noch das natürlich in
ebenso viele menschen zusammenkommen
denn einen vorfall geben muss ist ja
auch eine grundsätzliche das party
geschäft gingen ganz ist weiter wegen
solcher après ski partys geht es nun als
wären umschlagplatz vor allem richtung
norden nicht erst anfang märz so sagen
uns jetzt gastronomie mitarbeiter die
anonym bleiben wollen sondern bereits
ende februar wein ist die rede davon
dass es wohl einen positiven mitarbeiter
gibt genau zu der zeit haben sich wohl
auch carola wiegand und ihre freundinnen
angesteckt sie kamen zu sechst und
hatten bei ihrer rückkehr alle corona
symptome warum reagierte die
österreichische regierung so spät obwohl
sie von skandinavischen ländern bereits
anfang märz von infektionen in niesky
unterrichtet war die tiroler
landesregierung schließt zdf fragen dazu
bei der pressekonferenz heute aus nur
tiroler medien zugelassen die die
möglichkeit haben services eine pandemie
nicht eine reine tirol angelegenheit
aber natürlich ist es ein schaden die
gesamte diskussion auch was den
tourismus betrifft alle haben fehler
gemacht meint der wirt vom kids noch
nicht nur ist es sei eben eine besondere
situation gewesen eine die hoffentlich
so nie wieder vorkommt wenn die füllung
rausfällt oder sich die zahnwurzel
entzündet ist das für jeden unangenehm
für corona patienten aber unter
umständen ein schreckensszenario
denn welcher zahnarzt nimmt dieses
risiko auf sich
eine wichtige adresse könnten sogenannte
sogenannte korona schwerpunktpraxen
werden
hier soll die sicherheit von personal
und patienten gleichermaßen
gewährleistet sein
susanne gelhard berichtet aus rheinland
pfalz in der praxis von dr gerlach
werden zurzeit nur unbedingt
erforderliche eingriffe durchgeführt um
die gefahr einer corona infektion so
gering wie möglich zu halten
denn die ärzte müssen nah am rachen raum
arbeiten ohne den nötigen abstand dazu
kommt der sprühnebel der geräte der
viren leicht überträgt dr gerlach stellt
sich auf schwierige zeiten ein
rein statistisch müssen wir damit
rechnen dass natürlich immer mehr
positiv getestete vielleicht auch
symptomfreie aber durchaus viren
tragende patienten in die praxen kommen
das wird so sein
darauf richten wir uns ein für die
notfallbehandlung solcher patienten
wollen die deutschen zahnärzte nun
corona schwerpunktpraxen einrichten mit
erhöhten schutzvorkehrungen für
patienten und personal
insofern stehen wir gerade mit den
länderministerien in sehr engem kontakt
um dieses netz an versorgung für die
menschen aufzubauen
aber auch hier sind wir dann ganz
besonders darauf angewiesen dass wir
diese spezielle schutzausrüstung
bekommen die hier zusätzlich
erforderlich ist um hier sichere
behandlungen durchzuführen die übrigen
praxen sollen den anderen patienten zur
verfügung stehen ein restrisiko bleibt
deshalb fordert eine online petition von
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern die
bundesweite schließung von
zahnarztpraxen über 70.000 haben bereits
unterschrieben
dr gerlach will wie viele andere weiter
behandeln künftig auch corona patienten
die nötige schutzausrüstung soll laut
bundesregierung in den kommenden tagen
geliefert werden dann könnten die ersten
corona schwerpunktpraxen öffnen über die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der korona
pandemie informieren wir sie ausführlich
in einem zdf spezial direkt nach dieser
sendung jederzeit auf dem laufenden
bleiben sie mit unserer zdf heute app
dort erfahren sie auch warum so viele
menschen zur zeit ausgerechnet
toilettenpapier hamstern
unsere gesellschaft wird älter die zahl
der rentner steigt aber nicht die der
beitragszahler wie die renten kannst du
das stemmen soll dazu haben experten
heute empfehlungen vorgelegt demnach
sollen die altersbezüge langfristig 44
prozent eines durchschnittslohns nicht
unterschreibt
derzeit erhält ein rentner etwa 48
prozent ein wert für den auch
bundesarbeitsminister heil wirbt aus
berlin frank buchwald der
generationenvertrag unter druck zwei
jahre hat die renten kommission
nachgedacht ihren bericht hat minister
heute vorgestellt die kommission hat
bestätigt dass die gesetzliche rente die
tragende säule der alterssicherung sein
soll in den nächsten jahren und das
betriebliche und private altersvorsorge
gentzen hinzu kommen muss die experten
schlagen vor bis 2032 solle sich die
standardrente zwischen 44 und 49 prozent
von blut niveau einpendeln
dafür müsste sich der beitragssatz
zwischen 20 und 24 prozent bewegen
bisher gilt eine doppelte haltelinie
renten nicht unter 48 beiträge nicht
über 20 prozent am rentenniveau will
heil festhalten
für die opposition aber greift das alles
viel zu kurz die eigentliche herkules
aufgabe ist die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung in einer
erwerbstätigenversicherung umzuwandeln
wo auch wir abgeordnete aber auch
beamtinnen und beamte freiberufler
einzahlen am retten eintrittsalter
rüttelt der bericht nicht die fdp
empfiehlt dazu flexible lösungen wie in
anderen ländern schweden zum beispiel
macht und seit jahren vor wie man
erfolgreich einen flexiblen
renteneintritt einführen kann
die leute können flexible lösungen
finden die zu den lebensläufen passen
und gehen im schnitt auch noch später in
rente
der bericht eine diskussionsgrundlage
für einen politischen balance akt
zwischen finanzieller belastbarkeit und
gerechtigkeit unter den generationen
die bauern hatten massiv gegen die neue
strengere eu düngemittelverordnung
protestiert sie soll den nitratgehalt im
grundwasser senken
doch jetzt hat der bundesrat die
neuregelung beschlossen wegen der korona
krise bekommt deutschland für die
umsetzung aber mehr zeit von der eu ab
2021 müssen die besonders belasteten
gebiete ausgewiesen sein
dort gibt es dann strenge begrenzungen
für dünger und gülle
der sport hat es schwer in diesen tagen
aber der ball rollt weiter zumindest
virtuell beim stay at home cup des
fußball zweitligisten hannover 96 bei
diesem speziellen online fifa-turnier
zocken fünf spieler von hannovers profi
abteilung gegen rund 500 freizeitkicker
auf hannover seite unter anderem an der
konsole johannes horn der seine krone
erkrankung bereits überstanden hat
gespielt wird für einen guten zweck denn
die fünf euro startgebühr pro spieler
bekommt die caritas die sich um
wohnungslose kümmert so viele kreative
ideen um gutes zu tun
auch beim wetter erwartet uns gutes der
samstag wird nochmal ein warmer
frühlingstag mehr dazu gleich von es
intern das war es von uns für heute
schön dass sie dabei waren
claus kleber mit dem heute journal gegen
viertel nach zehn und ab morgen freut
sich an dieser stelle dann christian
sievers auf sie hier geht es weiter mit
dem spezial
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
entspannten abend